in person sorry man yeah that was my bad
though it's both of our bad dude I can't
believe we get into conversations
because that's what our conversations
are like on the phone
oh it's ugly yeah we talk about we're
talking about I'm like hear the phone
give a topics we don't we have
conversations well we have a media we
talk in the common store we don't really
know what we're talking about yeah yeah
it's limited it's very limited Bobby's a
hit and run conversationalist I find a
lot of times he'll get in the heel cup
say a couple things couple diss that
right and then he's gone he's off to the
next is that I think with just about
including me I cap he has like a limit
to how much he's going to yeah time
investment hmm he's out yeah in fact you
know I go to zoom AAA meetings and dude
I've seen you in one yeah I saw you dude
you were making me laugh oh my god
well why bro bro yeah I've I've been to
in my lifetime I probably been to a
hundred thousand eight years I've
laughed maybe twice like truly laughed
this dude because in zoom ones right all
I did was I just switched to his camera
even when other people are talking right
what a lurker on you bro all the people
were like talk you know you know other
people are sharing right I know
yeah or whatever right but I have just
do on the thing and just watching him
listening mm-hmm he was making me laugh
so hard bro you'd be doing like this
with your hands well I yeah I get fired
up some of the people shared I know you
were like into it but it was Mickey
wasn't purposely making me laugh it's
just the way he listens it's humorous
yeah it's hard to listen it's hard to
listen for a long time I feel like in a
row you know no dude some of those a
meetings on the zoom you guys take
breaks I guess I'm not what they tell is
not what I like classes are like
50 minutes long because I don't think
your brain supposed to work for three
hour stretches this is one that was I on
a Monday night where it's a men's one
mm-hmm
what do you don't like she didn't just
say something let's honor with the I
love you so much but you just listened
right oh you just didn't even like okay
I'm gonna just be quiet for a second
sorry but I'm trying to earn one of
those frickin boxed tits y'all got in
the you have a box tip you are apologize
you're right that is something that I'm
trying to work on in therapy and you
know I do listen to everything she says
right but I'm trying to be more
attentive to the things that she says
and her feelings and stuff hmm and she
has you know and we both she's beautiful
points I think she's beautiful he does
make beautiful points and he's also a
beautiful person in her heart yes if you
were alive today he'd be amazed at all
these people what I'm gonna say is you
know baby baby I love you baby I can't
do you know about Koreans this is a true
thing where they take a funeral photo
like a funeral portrait before they die
like you were saying you were talking as
if I was passed away in deceased right
would you guys be into that